[Music]
vladimir putin is not just any
politician he's the perfect character
for a spy movie and today's story has a
lot of spy movie material in it today
we're going to talk about a
confrontation between russia germany and
the united states a billion dollar mega
project and a person alexei navalny who
could overturn the entire energy policy
of a country as important as germany are
you ready let's get into the video
[Applause]
[Music]
now i'm sure that many of you have asked
yourself this question how much real
power does russia have remember that we
are talking about one of the largest
countries in the world but one which has
a smaller gdp than italy so
why is russia so important one reason is
natural gas take a look at this map
[Music]
on this map you can see how half of
europe depends on russian gas
practically all of central europe has
become accustomed to buying almost all
its gas from its eastern neighbour
russian gas
is close and cheap this includes of
course germany which is 60 dependent on
russian gas for years
the european union has been looking for
alternatives to diversify gas however if
the facts are anything to go by the
trend is clear
germany intends to become even more
dependent on russia
nordstream 2 to complete first two
branches as soon as june 2021
world oil meet nordstream 2 a gas
pipeline that directly connects russia
with germany with this gigantic pipeline
germany will be able to guarantee the
supply of russian gas without any
problem the project has cost
9.5 billion euros and it is nearing
completion the question is
is germany really going to be able to
finish nordstrom 2 well
keep watching because this whole project
is triggering a serious dispute
a dispute between germany and the united
states and to a large extent you could
say that this project could be rumoured
by this gentleman that you see on screen
alexey navalny the most famous
anti-putin opponent in russia this man
is a real threat to putin so much so
that in the summer of 2020 he was
poisoned with the notorious novichok and
if you've been following visualpolitik
for a while you'll already know that
novichok is a poison invented during
soviet times of course
navalny is not the main person
responsible for this story by far but
clearly the assassination attempt on his
life has been a catalyst
and you might be wondering but how much
power does navalny have
why is germany so interested in buying
gas from russia and why does the united
states want to stop him today we're
going to answer these questions but
first
let's have a look at a bit of history
[Music]
the flip side of denuclearization if
there is an anti-nuclear country part
excellence
it is germany in fact one of the most
important political parties in this
country are the greens who were founded
to call for the closure of nuclear power
plants decades after their inception you
could say that they have succeeded in
getting their way in just a few years
germany has shut down almost all of its
reactors
[Music]
[Applause]
to give you an idea in 2002 nuclear
power accounted for 19
of germany's energy mix today in 2021 it
is around
3 and the plan is to reach zero percent
as soon as possible
[Music]
however germany is also the largest
energy consumer in europe so by going
without nuclear power germany has to
produce more energy from other sources
well take a look at this graph
as you can see germany is becoming
increasingly green but it is still not
possible to rely 100 on green energy
sources
storing energy is very expensive and a
windmill or a solar panel only produces
energy when there is wind
or sunshine
the simplest is coal but it is also the
most polluting there is so what is the
only alternative left
exactly natural gas you could say that
natural gas is the least polluting
source of energy within the polluting
energies to give you an idea coal expels
820 tons of greenhouse gases into the
atmosphere for each gigawatt of energy
produced oil is about 720 tons gas
however is at 420 tons in other words it
pollutes half as much as coal to put it
another way we could say that in today's
world
gas is the new oil and germany is proof
of this
[Music]
in 1990 they produced 40 000 gigawatts
of power from gas
in 2020 they were producing more than 94
000 gigawatts
it is true that in relative terms gas
represents a smaller percentage of the
mix but don't forget that germany's
energy demand is increasing year by year
to give you an idea
germany currently consumes 90 bcms of
gas per year that is 90 billion cubic
meters of gas
per year well it is estimated that by
2034 it will be more than 110 bcms in
other words germany needs more and more
gas the question is
how do you get your hands on the extra
gas well let's take a look at that right
now
from russia with love natural gas
travels in two different ways
through gas pipelines or by ship using
liquefied natural gas technology
in this case the gas is converted into a
liquid conveniently transported and
taken to the destination country once
there the liquefied gas is processed in
a plant to convert it back into gas the
problem with this technology is that it
is expensive
and requires at least one such plant to
process the gas and you may ask does
germany have such a plant well for the
moment
no it is true that there are projects to
build one but for the moment
all the gas comes through the pipelines
and 60 of this gas
comes from russia and take note because
they are not the only ones who buy gas
from this country look at this map
[Music]
as you can see other countries like
finland and romania depend
100 on russian gas and i know what many
of you are thinking
so what's the problem there you go again
visualpolitik with your visceral hatred
towards russia don't many countries in
the world buy gas and oil from much more
authoritarian countries yes you're right
putin is by far not the biggest tyrant
selling natural resources to the rest of
the world but we also have to recognize
one thing putin is willing to use his
gas as a political weapon what's more
it wouldn't be the first time that he's
done so
for example in 2006 he cut off gas going
to ukraine over a political dispute
three years later he did it again and
this time the cutoff also affected
germany
why you may ask what does ukraine have
to do with germany well look closely at
this other map
in this map
you can see that until 2011 almost all
that gas went through ukraine or belarus
in other words if the ukrainians run out
of gas
so do the germans so what is the most
pragmatic solution very simple
build a gas pipeline connecting russia
directly to germany a pipeline across
the baltic
well that was the nordstrom one project
which was completed in 2012. however
germany still needs more gas and it does
not want to go back to using the
pipelines passing through ukraine
and that's how from the creators of
nordstrom 1 came nordstrom 2
revenge i don't know what many of you
are thinking so what's the problem in
the end
it doesn't change anything like it or
not russia was already selling russian
gas to europe it did it before nordstrom
1 and before nordstrom 2. the only
difference was the pathway the gas
traveled yes
you're right but there is a clear victim
in this story ukraine think about it if
russia can send their gas without
passing through ukraine they could cut
off ukraine's supply without any
problems from one day to the next
ukraine would be at russia's mercy and
all this explains why the first
countries to raise the alarm were all
the former communist republics
seven eu countries opposed nordstrom
you're active
these seven countries include poland the
czech republic the baltics and in
general all the countries that once
belonged to the soviet orbit and that is
when angela merkel said ah look how i
tremble the ex-communist countries are
standing up to me go home and leave me
alone and that's how in 2015 russian gas
company gazprom began construction of
the pipeline suddenly baltic sea was
once again filled with ships with cranes
designed to be able to deploy the
pipeline sections going across the sea
we are talking about one of the most
fascinating engineering projects ever to
be seen
a project that has already cost more
than 9.5 billion euros it seemed that no
one could stop it
and then comes the next player in our
story
[Music]
pressure from the united states the
united states and germany have always
been great allies and this is not only
because they are both part of nato while
france has turned its back on the united
states on many fronts such as for
example
the iraq war germany has always gone
hand in hand with the united states in
foreign policy and that's why this news
is so surprising
nordstrom 2 trump approves sanctions on
russia gas pipeline bbc
and i know what some of you are probably
thinking this must just be another
donald trump bluster right well nothing
of the sort
in fact these sanctions were passed in
congress by both democrats and
republicans there are many reasons why
the united states wants to prevent this
pipeline from being built at all costs
the first is purely geopolitical it is
in their interest to protect
ukraine which is an ally and they are
not interested in russia
in having so much bargaining power the
second is economic the united states
wants to sell its liquefied natural gas
to europe and that explains why these
first sanctions were enough for some
companies to abandon the project
2019 allseas which is a swiss offshore
pipeline construction company abandoned
nordstrom 2 to avoid sanctions however
for the time being no company has
received
any real economic punishment true the
united states approved the possibility
of imposing economic sanctions on all
companies involved in this project but
until then there was no such fierce
opposition to the pipeline
however everything changed in the summer
of 2020
[Music]
french swedish labs confirmed nalvani
poisoned
with novochuck dw again alexey novanley
is perhaps vladimir putin's greatest
political enemy novichok is a very
potent poison
used mainly by russian spies everything
points to this man having been poisoned
by people close to putin and although
navalny survived and has been treated in
a german hospital this news
changes everything suddenly france which
had no clear position on nordstrom 2 has
joined the club of countries opposed to
it before it was a question of pure
geopolitics now it is also a question of
ethics
it could be seen as a way to punish
putin for trying to assassinate his
political opponents
[Music]
just as the assassination of khashoggi
has scuppered many of bin salman's grand
projects in saudi arabia the attempted
assassination of navalny could scupper
vladimir putin's grand energy project to
give you an idea
one of trump's last measures before
leaving the white house was new economic
sanctions to stop the project
at the time of making this video more
than 18 companies had decided to abandon
the project
and the question the big question that
you may be asking now is what is joe
biden going to do
in principle biden is against the
pipeline but on the other hand he
doesn't want to take on germany either
so what is his answer well nothing more
and nothing less than to take a stand
watch this space
us to sanction russian vessel building
nordstrom 2 gas pipeline in baltic sea
r-e-f-e-r-l in other words biden has
said that he will keep
trump sanctions in place but only for
russian companies the russian vessel in
question is called fortuna and it is one
of those construction ships i was
telling you about earlier a ship with
huge cranes that can deploy all sections
of pipeline offshore well both
this ship and all the others that help
it to build the pipeline will receive
economic sanctions are these measures
enough to stop the project to date
everything points to the fact that they
are not in fact days after these
sanctions against fortuna were announced
the ship returned to work as if nothing
had happened
at the time of making this video only
148 kilometers remains to be built
of the 1 230 kilometers that's 764 miles
total length
in other words it seems almost
impossible that these timid sanctions
will kill the project however in
washington the republicans are ready to
put up a fight
ted cruz puts hold on biden's cia pick
burns over nordstream 2 pipeline
reuters i promised you a spy story and
here it is ted cruz and other republican
senators have stood up
they have said that they will not
approve the appointment of the new cia
director until biden approves tougher
sanctions
and for sanctions to be effective they
would have to affect german companies as
well don't forget
that if everything goes according to
plan almost the entire pipeline will be
completed by this summer in other words
if they really want to stop it they're
gonna have to take drastic measures and
yes that would include sanctioning one
of their most important allies this
might seem like a minor story but we are
really talking about one of europe's
great dilemmas on the one hand both
germany and the entire region have
enjoyed cheap natural gas for decades
nordstrom 2 would help european industry
become more competitive
on the other hand it would pose a threat
to ukraine a country of 44 million
people that has been in a terrible
crisis for years partly because of its
poor relations with russia so now the
question is over to you do you think
that nordstrom 2 is a good idea
do you think that it will be completed
or maybe the us will be able to stop it
you can leave me your answers down in
the comments and as always
don't forget that here at visualpolitik
we release new videos every week so
subscribe to the channel and hit the
little bell so you don't miss any of our
updates and if you liked the video
please give it a thumbs up and i'll see
you in the next one all the best
see you soon and if you want to learn
more about politics and hear even more
of my lovely voice
you can join us at reconsider media we
have a podcast at reconsider media.com
podcast see you there